my guest this week is the oscar-winning
American actor producer and world-class
Archer Gina Davis
after shooting to Fame in films such as
Beetlejuice she spent a large part of
her career now championing gender
diversity across the media
I want to ask her today though about
what words of advice Dustin Hoffman gave
her when dealing with tricky male
co-stars and how Susan Sarandon changed
her life when they filmed their iconic
Thelma and Louise movie
foreign
[Music]
Davis lovely to have you here thank you
congratulations on the Memoir thank you
as well and and I think there's a theme
in there that people may be surprised by
which is Faking it until you make it the
idea that you as an actor got your
confidence as you were going through
your career not the other way around
right tell me about that right yeah I um
I I was a a sort of a badass on screen
way before I ever you know felt like
that in real life but but the roles I
played actually had an impact on me
personally and and you know that that I
I and I I think exactly as you said
Pikachu make it that I was practicing
being somebody uh confident and you know
um comfortable in the world uh and and
it it was like you know an opportunity
to try it on and then incorporate it in
my real life how long do you think it
took how old were you and maybe you felt
like a badass in real life well maybe
around someone Louise was uh was the
first time that I felt like yeah I could
I could be kind of like this person yeah
I mean if you go on a crime spree with a
woman on a road trip exactly I haven't
really gone on any crimes freeze yet
uh but you know it's there the potential
is there we will definitely come back to
Thelma and Louise but that was in your
mid-30s so maybe around the 30s the book
is called dying of politeness and as
part a dedication to your parents who I
was fascinated even changed the spelling
of your name to avoid awkwardness right
well it wasn't that they changed it um
my real name giving him was Virginia and
since my aunt was Jenny they didn't want
to have the same nickname so my
three-year-old brother actually came up
with with Gina I don't know how he
spelled it when he said it out loud but
uh but my mom always made it g-e-e-n-a
and uh and later she said people seem to
love the way her name is spelled I said
yeah I just told them you didn't know
how to spell Gina and she said oh no no
I I grew up in an Italian neighborhood I
know exactly how to spell it why did you
spell it with two e's
well I didn't want anyone to think it
was China
so like vagina yeah as in the and uh I
was like oh my God my whole identity is
based on uh fear of vagina you know
unfair of of kind of stepping out of
line or drawing too much attention which
is a big part of what you talk about
growing up absolutely absolutely and yet
you went on to be an actor to be the
center of attention see that's the weird
thing was that from minute one I wanted
to be an actor from when I was three or
something and uh
which is to invite people to look at you
but I didn't want anyone to look at me
and I wanted to be smaller and take up
less space but maybe it's only in
hindsight maybe I realized if I could
pretend to be somebody else I could be
more you know uh have a fuller life if I
could pretend to be someone else because
you started with modeling as well which
is the ultimate look at me right right
exactly just about unwanted looking
though it's interesting a lot of your
writing a lot of your work is about
women right but it's the advice from a
male co-star quite early on Dustin
Hoffman he gives you a line if you are
going to have unwanted advances right
from male co-stars tell us about that
yes uh he was giving me advice every day
when I was working with him and uh and
he said you know never sleep with your
co-stars it's just a bad idea it doesn't
it's not good so here's what you say and
uh he told me to say
um thank you you're very attractive I
would love to but I don't want to ruin
the sexual tension between us
and uh and then I had that I had to use
it on somebody who was Jack Nicholson
yeah not just anyone he was Jack
Nicholson I was still uh I had done
Tootsie but but I was also still a model
and uh my modeling agent took me in a
couple other
models who were also actresses or wanted
to be actresses uh to LA and he knew
Jack Nicholson for some reason and so
every night we had dinner with Jack
Nicholson for this week and then one
time I got back home to the hotel it was
a message Gina please call Jack
Nicholson
contact Nicholson okay all right hello
Mr Nicholson this is Gina the model
and and he says hey Gina when's it gonna
happen and I was like why didn't I
realize this was gonna be what it was
about uh and uh but then I was like I
know what to say so I said uh
uh well Jack you know
um I am I have a feeling that we're
going to be working together someday and
I would hate to have ruined the sexual
tension between us
and it was like oh man where'd you get
that from but it worked did you say
Dustin Hoffman oh yeah okay because I
mean what's interesting about that line
and in the book you are exploring your
responses and criticizing yourself right
as well at times you call yourself a
wimp right you say all these sorts of
things and of course it's the power of
hindsight right and experience but that
particular line Dustin Hoffman gave you
is still about flattering the male Eagle
yes exactly because it included I would
love to you're very attractive right so
would you still use that sort of line or
what do you make of that has it stood
the test well no I wouldn't I wouldn't
need that need that line now I just
think nah you know whatever but um but I
suppose it shows you the precariousness
of the women's role right in these
working environments right right yeah
that he felt it would be necessary for
me to boost their ego at the same time
instead of saying no I'm not interesting
you you know yes yeah well I mean one of
the men that you also write about is
Bill Murray and you talk about working
with him and you describe I mean I
thought I'd let you describe it an
incident that goes on against your
consent right how would you describe
what happened right well uh it was
inappropriate from minute one of meeting
him uh I had gone to a hotel to
um meet with he was the director of this
movie also and there was a co-director
there and a producer
um so it wasn't like a booby trap or
something where I was going to be alone
with him in a hotel suite but as soon as
I walked in he said have you ever tried
the thumper which was some kind of uh
massage device a huge massage device and
I was like No No No and went to sit down
and he said no no we have to try you
have to try you have to lay on the bed
and try it and I was like no no and and
I tried my hardest to be polite but I'm
and certainly I'm not going to do that
and then he was so relentless that I
realized
I'm not going to get out of here until I
do this and so I kind of perched part
way on the bed and he put it on my back
but uh
but that was yeah that was very
questionable you know what that was
about and and I mean would you describe
that how would you describe that it well
it turned out later that I found out
that he was worried I was gonna be um
think that I was all that because I had
just won uh an Oscar and uh that I would
be on the set and think you know that
I'm superior to people I don't know what
he thought
um but uh that was to see if if he could
make me do something I didn't want to do
okay which is a real power play and very
uncomfortable huge power play yeah yeah
but but the reason I ask is because of
the way we describe things now perhaps
it has changed again when you look back
on things and I I wonder why perhaps you
don't describe it in stronger terms well
right because even
I'm realizing uh
after the book was done and everything
that when I describe it instead of
saying
talking about how inappropriate his
behavior was I'm talking about and I was
so sad to see that I didn't I wasn't the
kind of person yet who could prevent
that from happening you know and instead
of really all it's all it's all about
his behavior you know I suppose there's
still a restraint to you when you're
when you're doing it I'm still dying I'm
polite all right maybe slightly in
danger but but I mean you've of course
you've taken work with your Institute
where you look at bias you look at
behavior and and yeah it's interesting
you can't quite bring it about yourself
and about these sorts of high-profile
men that you're willing to name and talk
about right right yeah I I wonder if
that has something to do with why I was
so interested in women's empowerment and
everything is that I felt
not powerful you know and uh and I
wanted to try to help myself as well as
others I mean Bill Murray's been in the
news again in only the last few days
it's been allegedly settled uh had a
financial settlement with a female
production assistant over allegedly
straddling this woman kissing over masks
on set he said there's a difference of
opinion but shooting was stopped on the
production and we're in 2022. what's
your response to that
that he said um it was a difference of
opinion yeah and the whole story yeah
yeah it's it's bad it's bad it's uh
utterly inappropriate I mean
that anyone could think that that was a
difference of opinion when she was
forced to do something that she didn't
want to do
you know
that's not the definition of what
happened but I suppose hearing that
story and about I mean it's alleged I'll
say at this point and I know you don't
know the details I don't know the
details but all this time on I mean how
does that make you feel when you've just
described something that happened to you
at the end of the 80s
right with the same God well look yeah I
didn't I wasn't under the impression
that he would have
changed necessarily but I suppose the
world has changed and world has changed
there was a moment of change you thought
you hoped after Thelma and Louise yes
and you actually say in the book nothing
changed afterwards right but you say
everything in your life changed when you
met Susan Sarandon professionally
certainly yeah and also had a big impact
you know personally for you
what did she have that you didn't have
at that time uh
and ease and self-confidence in any
situation
um she knew what she thought about
things she knew how to react in the
moment I mean I was living in a world
where
the hours or minutes or days later I
would realize what I could have said or
should have said or should have done and
uh she just lived in the moment and was
very comfortable she sharing what she
thought I mean I'm not saying this was
confrontational but
um she just had an immediate ease and
new
how she felt about things when they
happened and and uh and I came to
realize that I you know that I didn't
even know how I forget about that I
didn't say what I was thinking I didn't
even know how I felt about situations
until I had time to to think about it
but from minute one you know I was like
wow I never met anybody like you before
I I do love the fact that women come up
to you still and say it's our favorite
movie we've exited out and you've
probably get worried about that and I'm
like I don't think you did I mean at
least what part do you think you're
acting up but I think it's we went on a
weekend just us girls or something like
that but uh you know if you think about
the stuff we do you know people think of
uh with some of these examples or maybe
a little bit Role Models or something
but I mean nothing we do should be
emulated except being in charge of our
own fate that was the thing that was the
whole the driving force in it but the
rest of the details yeah the crime
elements the rest was kind of criminal
have you ever been on a real-life road
trip with Susan no no but I was thinking
only recently that that would be kind of
a cool
um reality show yeah as soon as I
driving around the game you can't have a
sequel everyone who asks you about that
I know you you get very I'm not asking
that but the idea of you two together
right right driving around have you you
should ask her I wish I should ask her I
know it could be I mean we would love it
is she still in your life are you
friends oh yes yeah we're still very
very good friends yeah she's uh she's
fantastic to to be with she would often
say when we were shooting see how much
fun it is to work with women and I was
like yes you talk about the roles drying
up as you got older you never thought it
would happen to you I like the way you
describe but it's awful but you say
forced retirement I mean I know that
you're very polite but are you angry
about that it may be angry and and very
sad but but you know sometimes you
replace anger with sadness yeah but if
he was to really let it out Gina in the
studio and you know it's it's it's it's
not a laughing matter it's no no it
wasn't and you know I'd heard about this
phenomenon uh from from the very
beginning that roles drop off for women
once they reach 40 but I thought Meryl
Streep and all the other
um female actors were going to fix it
and even if it's still true that won't
happen to me because I'm playing you
know I'm in League of Their Own and all
that stuff so
um so it was stunning to uh to see it
also
happened to me yeah but I mean and then
I talked about the Gina Davis Institute
on gender in the media looking at female
representation I know you've set things
up like the Bentonville Film Festival to
look at this what have you learned
through that work that you you feel
perhaps is going to help change things
right what I focus on in the with my
Institute is on screen representations
and I started the whole thing because I
had a daughter
and started watching preschool shows
with her and saw a huge gender imbalance
so I'm like wait a minute we're training
them from minute one to have unconscious
gender bias you know girls see there's
not many of them there and Boise we do
all the interesting things so that's
that really spurred me on to want to try
to uh to change that but
most creators most writers most uh
Studio head people with with the green
light power are male and so uh you have
to be able to to
in order to achieve what I wanted to
achieve you have to get uh the uh the
men in power also to see the problem and
want to fix it and where do you feel we
are with that I mean as we talk Harvey
Weinstein's back in court we've
obviously had the metoo movement but do
you feel we're in a better place well as
far as Children's Entertainment I can
tell you that in the 18 years since we
started my Institute uh we have achieved
parity in the lead characters in both
children's television and movies made
for families so so that's good a huge
difference from when we started
um but the progress in other areas is
pretty glacial as far as like female
directors or editors or cinematographers
yeah so I mean your mood at the moment
about that would you say it's optimistic
are you in a pragmatic place where would
you say I'm uh I am an inpatient
Optimist okay so
um I you know I'm always
feeling like you know we can get there
we can't get there but it's it's it's
you know in some spheres it's going to
take decades to reach parity like we
can't snap our fingers and suddenly
Congress is half women it's going to
take decades we've still only seen a
woman in the white house right when it's
played on television exactly or in the
film exactly not quite ready yet yeah
for whatever the reason for whatever the
reason can I ask I mean while this
forced retirement's happening I know
that's when you are having your children
as well but that wasn't the reason as
discussed you take up archery I mean I
have to ask about this it's one of my
favorite facts I did not know about you
right and you're really good at it yeah
yeah yeah so how did that happen it was
uh it makes sense if I explain it um so
I had been very unathletic as a kid I
was so tall that I was sure that I must
be uncoordinated so I didn't want to try
anything and then I got cast in A League
of Their Own to play the best baseball
player anyone's ever seen so of course I
had to train and try to learn and uh and
I was kind of good at it and uh I was
able to pull off looking like I really
know how to uh play baseball
and I did learn it to some extent and
then I had to learn other skills for
other movies sword fighting and
horseback riding and Taekwondo and
different things and I was I was kind of
good at all those too so then I thought
I wonder if in real life I would be good
at some at a sport and what would what
would I choose and I happened to see
archery on television during the 96
Olympics right and uh I thought well
archery is so beautiful it's very you
know dramatic and uh
maybe I'll be good at that and so found
a coach took it up at 41 and then became
utterly obsessed with it but I mean you
nearly went and represented your country
well I was a semi-finalist in the
Olympic trials which is incredible I
know the last thing I ever expected was
to find myself in the Olympic trials in
my 40s what do you think it was about
the sport and you
I think I probably had a bit of a
natural yeah uh you know hand-eye
coordination or something but but I I
dove into it I became utterly obsessed
you know I was practicing you know four
hours a day and
um
I don't know I just was very determined
well I mean also just talking about
later on in your life a late diagnosis
of ADHD as well what did that mean for
you how did that explain or unpack some
of your world it uh it was such a relief
to find out that I didn't have a
character flaw necessarily because my
entire life as a kid as well
I couldn't start things I couldn't
finish them you know uh once we started
having homework that that took more than
one night to do
I had no ability to you know stretch
things out and uh it was very very
difficult and I was ashamed of that you
know that this was something wrong with
me and uh and my whole so for my whole
life I was something I had to hide that
I can't complete things and and all that
but
as soon as I found I was diagnosed with
ADD I was like oh my God that explains
everything it was such an Awakening and
uh and so okay so in other words I can
start
feeling like this is not my fault this
doesn't mean I'm a bad person you know
what I mean this is who you are it's
very and did you did you take anything
for it or did it change your approach I
didn't I didn't end up taking any um
medication for it but but it did change
my approach it it
made me realize that I needed
coping skills that would help deal with
that uh so for example if I if I felt
like I wasn't gonna
practice archery on a certain day which
I wanted to but am I going to make
myself get in the car I would make an
appointment for a brief time with my
coach in the morning and then once I'm
there I can stay all day and practice
but you know like little tricks like
that would you like to to do a lot more
acting again though do you think yeah
absolutely absolutely that's my thing
acting is my thing that's what I want to
do you know yeah well I mean at the same
time you've obviously kept yourself very
busy but I was thinking about two we had
Gloria all read on the program the
feminist lawyer and she was talking
about women getting more radical as they
get older do you do you feel that has
happened to you well so I worked I
worked with Polly Bergen once who was a
famous actress
when I worked with her she was 80. but
uh she had been quite famous and uh and
I couldn't believe how salty she was on
set to swear they're there right you
know and I was like whoa Paulie you
really yeah you're kind of like a sailor
and uh and she said oh I mean it used to
be my age you just don't give me [ __ ]
anymore and I was like okay then I'm
gonna be like you when I get to be here
this is what I'm heading for yeah are
there any dream roles for you that you
you think about uh there's one real life
character that I would like to play who
is Eleanor Roosevelt and the great thing
about that is uh she was famous her
whole life so I'm not going to age out
of being able to play her no I don't
know and she was very she was very tall
like me I think I could look very much
like her yeah well there's a great quote
that's always attributed to her about a
woman being like a tea bag you don't
know how strong she is until you put her
in hot water I don't know if it is
definitely her but I get I got given it
on a pincushion oh I love that that's a
great question so okay we've sorted it
Eleanor Roosevelt and you're going to do
a reality TV show with Susan sure yeah
well it's lovely to to talk to you and
and hear some of your memories that
you've shared in the book but also where
you think we're at at the moment Gina
Davis thank you so much thank you thank
you and thank you so much for being with
us and until we meet again take care and
goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]